la lava color rojo vivo empieza a ganar
protagonismo el volcán más volátil de
Filipinas el mayón entró en erupción y
votos cenizas los primeros incendios
surgieron tarde el pasado 11 de junio
después de una semana de Gran actividad
miles de personas que viven en un radio
de 6 kilómetros del cráter fueron
evacuadas
tuvimos esta sensación de que nuestro
final está cerca
la mayoría de los evacuados han vivido
en estos pueblos agrícolas durante
generaciones por lo que las evacuaciones
son particularmente difíciles
es muy difícil ser desplazado de tu casa
dejamos atrás nuestro ganado y no
sabemos cómo vamos a proveer Para
nuestras necesidades diarias
hay una sensación de miedo y sufrimiento
mientras los humos tóxicos envuelven la
región
para Amelia Morales es la segunda
tragedia a la que se enfrenta en
cuestión de días mientras despide a su
difunto esposo en medio del caos
Es realmente muy difícil porque no
tenemos dinero
el volcán actuando mal luego mi esposo
murió y ahora estamos atrapados en el
centro de evacuación
pero aún resta un número indeterminado
de personas que eligen quedarse Incluso
en áreas declaradas fuera de los límites
durante mucho tiempo los sismólogos
advierten que la erupción podría
volverse violenta evocando recuerdos de
hace cinco años en este mismo lugar
cuando decenas de miles fueron despla